Prof: Well,
post-colonial studies is really
by far the most varied and
eclectic of the identity fields
that we're passing in review in
this portion of the course:
eclectic really of necessity,
of course, because of the
immense variety of the materials
covered,
but also because of swirling
issues and controversies within
post-colonial studies or
"po-co,"
as it's affectionately known,
which kind of pose a number of
questions from the side that
keep things lively,
to say the least.
We are taking up only one
strand, one developmental
strand,
in post-colonial studies today,
a kind of progression from the
work of Said to the work of
Bhabha which is relatively
easily mapped,
simply in terms of the
intellectual agendas of each of
them,
but there's a great deal else
going on.
I suppose I should just mention
in passing certain topics that
we won't be discussing,
at least except possibly in
passing and that,
however, you might really be
interested in considering if you
do have an interest in this
field.
The first issue,
of course, is who says
"post-colonial,"
and who says that we're
necessarily out of colonialism?
Just because the local viceroy
packs up and goes home doesn't
necessarily mean that things
change all that significantly in
the so-called postcolonial
setting,
and it needs to be taken into
account,
seriously considered,
whether or not one isn't still
in colonial or colonial studies
and that the moniker
"post-colonial"
might therefore be
inappropriately applied.
There's also the question that
arises in the study of the
so-called third world,
which is obviously in itself a
controversial term.
It arises as that which is not
comprised as either of the great
sort of trajectories of the
superpowers during the Cold War.
There is no Cold War,
at least allegedly no Cold War
any longer,
and so the question of the
status, nature,
and structure of the third
world is obviously wide open.
But the issue I mean to touch
on in terms of post-colonial
studies is whether,
in fact, crises and concerns
with respect to the third world
are necessarily always to be
understood in terms of
coloniality.
Is it just that certain parts
of the globe have been colonized
that constitutes them as they
are and shapes their identity?
Said in a very interesting way
takes this up in trying to
figure out how it is that German
Orientalism so very closely
resembles French Orientalism,
even though the Germans had no
colonial interests in the Middle
East.
During the whole period--the
early nineteenth century in
particular,
when German Orientalism is
practically indistinguishable
from the French,
takes up the same concerns,
and has the same interests--
how is it that the French are
undoubtedly in some sense,
in Said's view,
determined by their colonial
interests,
and the Germans,
who seem so much to reflect
French attitudes,
have no colonial interests,
at least in the Middle East?
Said sort of quite honestly
tries to come to terms with
this.
His answer is,
"Well, German Orientalism
is simply derived in scholarly
terms from French Orientalism.
It has the stamp of that
thinking and reflects that
thinking,"
and so there you are.
He could have said on the other
hand,
however, that a certain mindset
toward the third world--
and this is the point I have
been making about this
particular issue--
dictates a certain way of
structuring one's thought about
that world,
irrespective of whether or not
there are colonial interests
involved.
That's what I mean by raising
the question,
"Is coloniality always at
issue in cases of this
kind?"
There's a kind of confusion in
thinking about these things,
a confusion which is distilled
in the history of the British
East India Company--
which is both nationalist and,
as it were,
globalizing--but a confusion
which comes out in more recent
history of coloniality,
and that is:
well, what drives coloniality?
Is it always nationalism or,
as seems increasingly the case
in the modern world,
is it transnational interests
in globalization?
In other words,
is the relationship between the
colonist and the colonized a
relation of some sort of
metropolitan nation with respect
to a provincial empire,
or is it a relation which is
dictated and generated by the
economic interests of
globalization?
This is a complex subject which
generates a great deal of debate
in the field that we take up
today,
but in a way,
we can't just say,
"Well,
nationalism isn't important
anymore,
now it's globalization"
because actually nationalism
seems to have reappeared in the
Bush foreign policy,
even possibly to be continued
in the Obama foreign policy,
and so there's a complex
relationship still between
nationalism and globalization
that needs to be considered and
thought about if these social
relations are to be clearly
understood.
Finally, there is within
post-colonial studies--
especially among those who
represent the various colonized
interests of the world--
there is the question,
to borrow an expression from
Gayatri Spivak,
"How should the subaltern
speak?"
It has to do most vividly with
the very question,
"Which language should the
subaltern speak in?"
Spivak's own question is,
"Can the subaltern speak
at all?"
and Said raises that question,
as you notice,
during the course of his
analysis;
but the related issue is,
okay, suppose that the
subaltern can speak--suppose
Ngugi wa Thiong'o,
for example,
can write a novel.
What language should it be
written in?
Ngugi campaigned in his more
recent career not to write in
English and also to urge other
African writers to write in
native languages and not in the
language of the colonizer.
This is a frequently heard
opinion from within
post-colonial studies,
but debate swirls around it
because,
of course, the means of
circulation of literary
influence is languages that draw
upon international publishing
possibilities and not languages
that can only be grasped and
published and disseminated
locally.
So there, too,
you have a complicated issue or
controversy on both sides,
of which there is much to say;
but as I say,
for us today it's simply a
question--
or more simply a question,
because when you've got Homi
Bhabha on the syllabus there's
no such thing as simplicity--
so I should say it's a question
of following the trajectory or
development specifically between
Said and Bhabha.
In beginning to think about
Said, I thought we wouldn't
think about him.
We'd think instead,
for a moment at least,
once again about Virginia
Woolf.
In the second chapter of A
Room of One's Own,
this young woman,
Mary Beton, Mary Seton,
Mary Carmichael--whoever she
is, is sitting in the British
Library.
She's thought that she'd spend
the morning trying to figure out
what scholars think about women.
After all, the subject is women
and fiction.
I'm supposed to be addressing
these undergraduates on this
subject: "what do I know
about women?
I'd better go to the library
and find out."
So she expects just to find a
couple of books and she'll be
all set.
Instead she is simply
overwhelmed, and there's this
avalanche of material.
She submits maybe a dozen or
two call slips and then sits
back waiting for the material to
appear.
Of course, the point of it is
that everything in the British
Library on what turns out to be
the voluminous subject of women
is written by men,
right?
Everything.
She begins to take note of the
way these things are described
in the sort of pre-computer
database.
That is to say,
how do you classify the various
things that men have to say
about women?
This is the way it goes:
"condition of Middle Ages
of;
habits in the Fiji Islands of;
worshipped as goddesses by;
weaker in moral sense than;
idealism of;
greater conscientious of;
South Sea islanders age of
puberty among;
attractiveness of;
offered as sacrifice to;
small size of brain of;
profounder sub-consciousness of;
less hair on the body of;
mental, moral and physical
inferiority of;
love of children of;
greater length of life of;
weaker muscles of;
strength of affections of;
vanity of;
higher education of;
Shakespeare's opinion of;
Lord Birkenhead's opinion of;
Dean Inge's opinion of;
La Bruyere's opinion of;
Dr. Johnson's opinion of;
Mr. Oscar Browning's opinion of;
and dot, dot,
dot--the list can continue.
In other words, she sits there.
She's simply overwhelmed,
and what she of course is
telling us is that there's lots
and lots and lots and lots of
opinions on record about women,
all of them expressed by men.
So now thinking about Edward
Said,
if Edward Said had taken up
Virginia Woolf's project,
if Edward Said had undertaken
to write A Room of One's Own,
the title of it would have
been Female-ism,
right?
That's precisely what he means
by "Orientalism,"
the vast body of information--
some of it scholarly,
some of it just sort of sheerly
doxological--
the vast body of information
about peoples called
"Oriental"
by and large,
especially in the
nineteenth-century tradition.
Said's main concern is the
peoples of the Middle East,
and he shows how it is that
there's a certain reason why
this is an appropriate term to
use for that tradition of
scholarship and philology in the
nineteenth century.
In any case,
the vast body of material
published about these people--
and it's perfectly true that
there are the infinitely long
shelves of the library devoted
to multivolume treatises on this
topic,
all of them written by us in
the West--
us--about this other who is
perpetually in our imagination
and constructed by us in the
variety of ways that Said
discusses on page 1811,
the right-hand column.
He says toward the bottom of
the column:
Orientalism is premised upon
exteriority,
that is, on the fact that the
Orientalist,
poet or scholar,
makes the Orient speak,
describes the Orient,
renders its mysteries plain for
and to the West.
Just as in Woolf,
men's opinions about women
getting themselves expressed in
books make the subject of woman
clear to an audience of men.
All right.
So before moving in with some
more depth and precision into
Said's text,
let me quickly explain what I
mean by saying that Said and
Bhabha constitute a kind of
sequence.
I'm thinking in particular of
Elaine Showalter's distinction
between feminist and
gynocritical criticism.
You remember the distinction
which is echoed,
by the way, in Gates's essay.
The distinction is:
first you get criticism in
which the treatment of women in
literature by men is the focus
of attention,
and then subsequently you get
criticism in which the women's
tradition,
the voice of women themselves,
is the focus and,
as Showalter believes,
the more fruitful terrain for
criticism.
You can see that in that
context, by way of making that
distinction,
you can see that Said is
decidedly phase one because,
of course, Orientalism is about
the treatment of the Middle
Eastern other by the West.
It can be slotted into that
same moment.
Then Homi Bhabha obviously in a
variety of ways takes up the
subject position of the
colonized, of the subaltern.
He doesn't leave out the
subject position of the
colonizer because he sees them
as being radically interrelated,
but he plainly is as interested
in a variety of ways of talking
about the traditions of the
colonized as he is of talking
about the way in which
colonization takes place and
expresses itself.
So in that sense,
we can see Said and Bhabha as
belonging to these two phases as
mapped by Showalter.
As I say also in passing by
Gates--and I'm sorry for the
confusion of this heading
[gestures to board]--
actually there's another way in
which Said and Bhabha can be
understood as phase one and
phase two.
That has much more to do with
the tradition of literary
theory,
which in their ways both
Showalter and Gates have
rejected,
insisting that one needs to
commandeer white male literary
theory for one's own purposes.
I suppose it's a question of
how this issue doesn't come up
in Said and Bhabha.
It could perhaps be answered by
saying that precisely in the
situation of colonialism,
the intellectuals--third world,
colonized intellectuals--
nevertheless are educated in
high-octane male metropolitan
institutions,
by which of course one means
primarily Oxford and Cambridge.
In a certain sense,
they come to identify--
and this is not actually a
thing apart from Bhabha's
argument about hybridity--
they come to identify in some
measure with the educational
agenda of the colonizer and
participate in it.
Now that's speculative.
It may simply be that we have
missed out on those moments when
Said and Bhabha,
too, may be talking about the
way in which the white male
tradition of literary theory
needs to be appropriated;
but for the moment what I want
to point out is this:
Said's Orientalism works very
much in the historical moment of
what we call structuralism.
That is to say,
it's primary concern is with
the binary opposition,
a mutual and interdependent
binary opposition of central
self and decentralized other
including,
as we'll see in a minute,
the way in which the
construction of the otherness of
the other is actually covertly
also at the same time a means of
constructing,
defining, and delimiting the
nature of selfhood,
or in this case of being
Western.
There is a fundamental binarism
in Said's point of view,
which by the way has often been
criticized,
and it's been criticized most
often from the standpoint of
Bhabha--
if only because he's constantly
referring to Derrida's famous
essay,
"The Double Session,"
which is about Mallarmé,
and also because he
appropriates a great deal of the
language and style of Derrida.
You can see that Bhabha takes,
with respect to the binarism of
structuralism,
a deconstructive attitude.
In other words,
his sense of these relations
breaks down into,
at the very least,
a redoubling sense of what he
calls "double
consciousness"
so that one can't clearly
identify colonizer and colonized
as a binary opposition.
It's more complicated than
that, and it's a series of
issues that turns on a highly
Derridian sense of what one
might mean by difference.
All I want to say is that the
relation, Said-Bhabha,
is phase one-phase two in that
regard as well.
By the way, this is a tendency
that one can find in other forms
of theory having to do with
identity.
The relationship between the
classical feminism that we have
been discussing so far and the
gender theory that we will be
discussing on Tuesday,
especially in the case of
Judith Butler,
is once again a relation that
could be understood as between
structuralism and
deconstruction.
There, too, you have a not
completely overlapping but,
from the standpoint of our
concerns in literary theory,
nevertheless rather interesting
way in which this succession,
Said-Bhabha,
is phase one-phase two in two
different ways that can be
identified,
I think, usefully.
All right.
So that then about their
relationship.
So what about Said?
How do we get at the issues
that Said wants to talk about
and understand the way in which
he thinks they have integrity?
I think I'd like actually to
begin with a word or two about
truth,
because Said makes it clear
that in a way,
the demonization of Orientalism
that his project undertakes
isn't really undertaken because
Orientalism is necessarily a
pack of lies.
Maybe he waffles a little bit
about this, but it's not really
ultimately the point for him
whether Orientalism lies or
tells the truth.
This is the way he puts it on
page 1802 in the right-hand
column:
… [A]
third qualification.
One ought never to assume that
the structure of Orientalism is
nothing more than a structure of
lies or myths which,
were the truth about them to be
told,
would simply blow away.
I myself believe that
Orientalism is more particularly
valuable as a sign of
European-Atlantic power over the
Orient than it is as a veridic
discourse about the Orient...
Nevertheless,
what we must respect and try to
grasp is the sheer
knitted-together strength of
Orientalist discourse…
In other words,
one of Napoleon's adjutants
during Napoleon's campaign
through Egypt wrote a ten-volume
Eastward de l'Egypt.
Many of the texts which
Said mentions in passing in his
introduction to Orientalism are
just as long.
You've got fifty-volume,
sort of gigantic scholarly
undertakings,
and you've got to admit,
well, if they are saying that
much,
there's got to be something in
it that's true.
There is, after all,
a great deal of knowledge of a
certain kind,
at least, that has gone into
thinking of this kind,
and so one can't just say,
"My point is that none of
it's true."
Said is at pains to make a
distinction, therefore,
between truth and value.
It's not that Orientalist
discourse is necessarily true or
false.
It is the case though that it
is insidiously devaluate of its
object of attention--
that there is an implicit
euro-centrism which Said does go
so far as to consider a form of
racism in Orientalism,
quite irrespective of any
measure or degree of truth that
what are,
after all, the meticulous
researches of a lot of these
characters turn up.
For example,
on page 1812,
the left-hand column,
he says:
My analysis of the Orientalist
text therefore places emphasis
[this is about a third of the
way down]
on the evidence,
which is by no means invisible,
for such representations as
representations,
not as "natural"
descriptions of the Orient.
Now we might pause for a minute
over that as a possible object
of critique because at the end
of his essay,
or at the end of the
introduction as you have it,
you notice Said saying,
"Look,
I don't take up here the
question of how one might
actually write correctly
>
about these people."
He doesn't take up,
for example,
the question of what it might
be like to be sort of a
representative of these
minorities or colonized figures
and to write about oneself.
He doesn't really take up the
question of whether the bias of
somebody else writing about me,
a man writing about a woman,
is worse than the bias of my
own preconceptions and
prejudices about myself.
He admits that he doesn't
really have an advanced theory
that secures one kind of
representation as true or
authentic and secures another
kind of representation as bias
and inauthentic.
He says, "Another scholar
will perhaps take this up.
I leave it alone in my
book," and it is left
alone,
the problem being that the
claim remains that he does--
anticipating many other people
who have written on this
subject--
he does impugn Orientalism as
mere representation:
that is to say,
as the opposite because it is a
representation,
the opposite of a natural
evocation of an ethos or world.
So we just do want to put a
little question mark in the
margin and then say,
"Well, fine.
Granted this is all
representation,
where is the text?
Where could the text be that
would be natural?"
Is there, for example,
any such thing,
as we've asked ourselves over
the course of the semester,
as a natural sign?
The sign being arbitrary,
it does place us already pretty
securely in the realm of
representation.
So all of these questions are
then posed by Said's sense of
the relationship between truth
and value in the history of
Orientalist scholarship.
Now where is he coming from?
He's quite open about it,
and it's perhaps worth pausing
over an idea common to the two
scholar-theorists who matter
most to him,
Michel Foucault and the Italian
Marxist Antonio Gramsci.
First of all,
just to pass in review the way
in which he's indebted to
Gramsci on page 1803,
the left-hand column,
Said says:
Culture, of course,
is to be found operating within
civil society,
where the influence of ideas,
of institutions and of other
persons works not through
domination but by what Gramsci
calls consent.
In other words,
it's not just a question of
having forced down your throat
certain ideas of concepts or
laws,
for that matter,
but a circulation of knowledge,
so called, of feeling about
things,
of ideology,
which through consent
establishes certain attitudes of
bias.
This is the distinction that
Gramsci makes between the way in
which one is imposed on by
actual power and authority and
the way in which one is imposed
on by the circulations of what
we've been exposed to in the
past as being called
"ideologemes."
So to continue:
In any society not totalitarian
[says Said],
then, certain cultural forms
predominate over others,
just as certain ideas are more
influential than others;
the form of this cultural
leadership is what Gramsci has
identified as hegemony.
This is a term that you will
frequently encounter,
particularly in Marxist
criticism, but it is also a term
very closely related to what for
most Western readers is more
famous in the work of Michel
Foucault,
the term "power"
or sometimes
"power/knowledge."
As you will learn in the
excerpt from Foucault that
you'll be reading on Tuesday,
Foucault like Gramsci makes a
distinction between power merely
as that which is exercised by
the police,
by the legal arm of society,
by the dictator,
by the government,
and by power as the ways,
the frequently insidious ways,
in which knowledge is
circulated and made hegemonic--
that is to say,
made authoritative.
Foucault is fascinated by the
structure of this circulation of
knowledge.
That is, in fact the essential
subject matter of all of his
late work,
the way in which we are
thinking that we are sort of
free contemplative agents in the
world,
in fact browbeaten by
structures of opinion
circulating around us that lull
us into feeling that we are in
the presence of the truth,
whereas of course,
we're only in the presence of
one form or another of motivated
bias.
Both Gramsci and Foucault make
the distinction between absolute
power and, as Gramsci calls it,
hegemony and,
as Foucault calls it,
power/knowledge.
Said is talking here about
He's not talking about the
imposition of law through force
or any other means on a
colonized world.
He's talking about the way in
which opinions construct that
world and simultaneously
reinforce the authority of those
who generate the opinions.
I think it's important to point
this relatively subtle
distinction out:
he does, however,
disagree from Foucault in one
respect.
On page 1813 he goes back to
what we already know about
Foucault, which is Foucault's
interest in the author function
as opposed to the author.
Authors, generally speaking,
Foucault wants to say,
are not authorities but simply
vessels of forms of opinion.
Certain authors who come very
close to being authority we call
founders of discursivity,
but even in their cases it's
the nature of the discourse and
not their existence as authors
which is important.
Said wants to say,
"I take authors a little
bit more seriously than
that," and he does on page
1813 in the right-hand column
where he says:
Foucault believes that in
general the individual text or
author counts for very little;
empirically [that is to say,
"through my
experience"],
in the case of Orientalism,
and perhaps nowhere else I find
this not to be so.
In other words,
the author is the central
philologist,
and social historians,
explorers, and demographers who
have written so extensively on
this part of the world are
authorities.
They are the oracles from which
generalized and ultimately
commonplace opinions disseminate
as power/knowledge.
It's not a question,
therefore, of a kind of silent
drumbeat of opinion expressing
itself over and over again,
which is more what interests
Foucault.
So Said, as I say,
distinguishes himself subtly
from Foucault in that regard
while nevertheless confessing
openly the influence both of
Foucault and of Gramsci on his
way of approaching his material.
So as a circulation of power,
the effect of Orientalism is
something that ultimately
concerns Said.Well,
he says this somewhat
rhetorically because it
obviously does concern him that
it has an effect on the peoples
in question,
but what ultimately concerns
Said is the effect of
Orientalism on the Euro-centric
mind,
indeed the degree to which it
even can be said to construct
the Euro-centric mind,
page 1806, the right-hand
column:
… [M]y real argument is
that Orientalism is--
and does not simply
represent--a considerable
dimension of modern
political-intellectual culture,
and as such has less to do with
the Orient than it does with
"our"
world.
Now here you can see the degree
to which Said is saying
something very similar to what
Toni Morrison said in her essay.
The existence of black as
absence needs to be understood--
for example,
if we are studying the history
of American literature--
as the means of constructing
whiteness,
of that which liberates
whiteness from the forms of
constraint under which it's been
chafing at the bit.
Morrison, of course,
develops this argument
beautifully,
and she quite clearly takes it
from the fourth chapter of
Hegel's Phenomenology of Mind
as a way of understanding
the master-slave dialectic.
In other words,
in Hegel it's clear as Hegel
develops the idea that master
and slave are absolutely
necessary to each other in a
structure of mutuality.
The master isn't the master,
can't define himself as free or
superior without the existence
of the slave.
The trickiness that the slave
learns being in the position of
subordination involving the
development of all sorts of
complicated skills means
ultimately that the slave
becomes,
as it were, that which drives
the master technologically and
ultimately controls the master
in a kind of fable of class
reversal,
which continues to reverse
itself again and again and again
on various grounds.
This is the fable,
which at the same time is a
philosophy of class relations
that structures Morrison's
argument and which,
I think, also structures Said's.
I want to make the transition
to Bhabha because obviously this
is a form of binarism.
The two signifiers in relation
to each other need each other in
the way that we described when
we were discussing Saussure and
structuralism.
I can't simply say that a red
light has positive value.
You remember the whole
argument: I have to see the red
light in the context of the
semiotic system to which it
belongs.
I have to see it as being
different from,
or opposed to,
something else in order to
grasp it.
I cannot know it positively,
in other words;
I can only know it negatively.
This basic concept of
structuralism in the Saussurian
tradition is what creates,
is what shapes binary arguments
of the kind that one finds in
Said.
That we know ourselves
negatively as the not-other is
the basic principle,
the theoretical principle which
underlies obviously aspects of
the argument which are also,
as Said says, empirical.
Yes, I can say it's a
structuralist idea,
but I really believe it because
I've seen it in operation.
It's not just structuralism in
other words.
It shares, however,
with structuralism a
theoretical predisposition.
Bhabha, if you look at page
1879, openly criticizes the
premise of binarism of this
kind--
not just any binarism,
but he actually does go
directly back to Hegel.
In other words,
he identifies the source of
thinking of this kind,
bottom of 1879,
right-hand column,
when he says:
It is this ambivalence that
makes the boundaries of colonial
"positionality"--
the division of self/other--and
the question of colonial power--
the differentiation of
colonizer/colonized--
different from both the
Hegelian master/slave dialectic
or the phenomenological
projection of Otherness.
He goes on to mention other
things,
but I just want to focus on
this as a moment in which Bhabha
is distinguishing himself as
clearly as he can from the
project of Said.
Now the passage I just read
begins with the word
"ambivalence."
What does Bhabha mean by
ambivalence?
Let's try to start there and
see if we can work our way into
Bhabha's complex thinking on
these matters,
first by way of the notion of
ambivalence.
I'm going to put this in terms
of an historical example because
I hope that will make it a
little clearer.
There is the ambivalence of the
colonizer toward the colonized.
In other words,
it's not just one mindset that
drives colonization.
In the historical experience of
England in the East India
Company,
there are two distinct phases,
phases which actually repeat
themselves recurrently even
throughout the twentieth
century.
The first in the eighteenth
century is the period of the
government of the East India
Company by Warren Hastings who
in a certain sense was
interested in what we call
"going native"
and also encouraged all of his
provincial administrators to do
likewise.
Hastings, in other words,
in Saidian terms knew a great
deal about the Orientalized
other.
He knew all the local languages
and dialects.
He knew all the customs.
He really knew everything there
was to know and in a certain
sense was a person who did go
native while at the same time
wielding with an iron grip of
authority power over the
colonized other.
He himself then embodies a
certain ambivalence in not
giving an inch as to the actual
control of authority,
while at the same time seeming
to become one with the other.
Then there is the historical
ambivalence which expresses
itself in a completely different
attitude,
an attitude which surfaced in
the East India Company early in
the nineteenth century under the
supervisorship of Charles Grant.
There had been a tremendous
revival of fundamentalist
religion,
mainly Methodism,
in England, and this
evangelical enthusiasm spread
itself into the interests of the
empire.
Charles Grant and others like
him no longer had any interest
at all in going native but,
on the contrary,
insisted that a standard of
Englishness and,
in particular,
the standard of the English
Bible--
the coming of the English book
that Bhabha talks about at the
beginning of his essay--
be firmly implanted,
and that the imposition of
Englishness on the colonized
other be the agenda of
colonization.
The famous historian Thomas
Babington Macaulay codified this
attitude in a famous,
and soon to be infamous,
document he wrote called
"The Minute on
Education,"
which insisted that the
education of the Indian people
under the regime of the East
India Company be conducted
strictly according to English
models: that missionaries no
longer try to adapt their ideas
to local customs and folk ways
but that everything be strictly
anglicized.
This is a completely different
attitude toward colonization,
and it can be understood as a
sort of historical ambivalence.
I'd actually like to pause over
an example of what you might
call the Warren Hastings moment,
a vicious example although an
absolutely fascinating one in
the disturbing masterpiece by
John Ford called The
Searchers.
I hope some of you at least
know that film.
The John Wayne character is
sort of a lone stranger--
which is of course not
infrequent in the western--
who shows up at the house of
some relatives and hears that a
daughter has been abducted by
native Americans,
by Indians.
Now the thing about John Wayne
is that in this film is that
he's a vicious racist,
that he absolutely hates the
Indians,
but he is not a vicious racist
from the standpoint of
ignorance.
He is in fact a person who has
himself, in a certain sense,
gone native.
He knows all the Indian
languages and dialects.
He knows all their customs.
He has throughout a lifetime
made a careful study of the
people he hates,
and this is a volatile mixture
to be exposed to in a film
because we are much more
comfortable with the idea that
hatred arises out of ignorance,
right?
What is so deeply disturbing
about John Ford's The
Searchers is that it is a
portrait of absolutely vicious
racism: again Said says,
"Hey, it's not necessarily
truth,
but we do have to acknowledge a
certain local,
thick description.
We have to acknowledge that
there's quite a bit of
information
>
at this person's disposal,
and all of that is borne out in
the characterization of John
Wayne in this film.
Warren Hastings was a lot like
that.
Warren Hastings knew everything
about people whom he ultimately
didn't really respect and whom
he insisted on ruling with the
iron fist of authority.
That's the kind of thing that
Bhabha is thinking about when he
thinks about the ambivalence of
the colonizer,
the relationship between
knowledge and value as it's
already been enunciated in Said
but also the fact that there is
more than one mindset for the
colonizer.
There is the local knowledge
mindset,
and there is the sort of
raising the absolute unequivocal
standard of the colonizer that
these are two different
attitudes,
each of which dictate different
strategies,
particularly strategies of
education.
So that's the ambivalence of
the colonizer.
Then there is the ambivalence
of the colonized,
and that, too,
has to be understood as a
complex relation to co-optation.
The anecdote with which Bhabha
begins, I think,
is fascinating and well worth
attending to.
You have not a colonizer but
someone thoroughly co-opted,
an evangelical converted
Christian of Indian descent who
represents,
in a way, that the people he
finds sitting under the trees
reading the Bible consider to be
completely authentic because he
believes and is perfectly happy
to believe that the Bible,
and for that matter
Christianity itself,
is an English gift.
But he's met with the response
of people who resist that,
who say, "This is very
interesting stuff.
We wish we could have some
local authority for it.
Our understanding is we got
this book directly from God,
right?
That's our understanding and we
have our own attitude toward it.
Sure, maybe we'll get baptized
one of these days,
but in the meantime we got to
go home and take care of the
harvest, so we'll get around to
that.
Don't worry about it.
By the way, if we get baptized
we certainly can't take the
Eucharist because that's eating
meat.
We don't eat meat.
We are who we are."
You can see that these
cunningly insinuated provisos to
the attitude that the missionary
wants to inculcate in them in a
very real way completely
undermines his purpose.
They don't think of it as the
English Bible.
They won't accept it as the
They will only accept it as an
authority that's mediated by
their own values,
which transforms the document.
You can see it again--this
is1813, as Bhabha points out.
This is precisely at the moment
when we're moving,
when the regime of authority is
moving from the Warren Hastings
paradigm to the Charles Grant
paradigm.
It's no longer possible to
think in terms of adapting the
Bible to local beliefs and
circumstances.
This is a moment in which the
complexity of the attitude of
the colonized is brought up.
There's the attitude of the
suborned missionary,
and there's the more
complicated and interesting
attitude of the people he
encounters sitting under these
trees.
Turn to page 1881,
the left-hand column.
This is a very difficult
passage.
Everything in Bhabha is
difficult.
I think I want to gloss it by
suggesting to you that what he's
talking about is that the
ambivalence which--
and we might as well say right
out that he has a term for this
ambivalence,
and it's "hybridity"--
is the double consciousness of
the colonized hovering between
submission--
that is to say,
submission to authority but
with a difference,
submission to authority on
one's own terms,
and on the other hand,
acquiescence in authority as
given,
which of course is basically
the position of the missionary.
With that said,
I'll read the passage in which
Bhabha describes this hybridity
in the double consciousness of
the colonized:
The place of difference and
otherness,
or the space of the
adversarial, within such a
system of "disposal"
as I have proposed,
is never entirely on the
outside or implacably
oppositional.
[Not just, in other words,
again as a question of us
versus them.]
It is a pressure,
and a presence,
that acts constantly,
if unevenly,
along the entire boundary of
authorization [which is also
authority],
that is, on the surface between
what I've called
disposal-as-bestowal [I take
that meaning submission--
simply "okay,
fine, I give in"]
and disposition-as-inclination
[which is "hey,
I kind of like that,
I go along with it,
I give in spontaneously"].
Now to give in simply as a form
of recognizing that one's
beaten,
as a form of submission,
puts one in the position of
what Bhabha calls "sly
civility."
This is the position that I'd
like to go back to for a moment
as being very closely related to
what Gates calls signifyin'.
Bhabha gives a number of
examples of this sly civility in
his text,
but of course it's all present
in the clever and wonderfully
rich ironies of these figures
sitting under the trees in his
opening anecdote.
Let me just give you an example
of how sly civility works as a
form of signifyin' and as a
stance of colonized resistance,
a recuperation of the will,
perhaps in a post-modern sense,
which is nevertheless not
rebellious,
not in any way envisioning an
overthrow of authority,
but is a means of living in the
framework of authority.
Just a quick example and then
I'll let you go.
Two African-American people are
having a conversation in the
presence of a white person,
and they cheerfully and with
broad smiles on their face refer
to this person in his presence
as Bill.
Now "Bill"
is a derisive and derogatory
term for white people,
and the white person standing
there has two choices in
response to hearing himself
referred to as "Bill":
he can either take umbrage and
say,
"Why are you saying that
about me?
I'm a nice guy.
You don't want to say
that," in which case the
needling effect of the term has
taken hold;
or he can play the fool and
pretend that he doesn't know
that he's being signified on and
pretend that,
well, it's perfectly okay to be
called "Bill."
Either way you see it's a
win/win situation.
This guy, Bill,
is the slave owner,
right?
He likes to get along with
people,
so he's sitting around having
this conversation and he hears
them calling him
"Bill,"
right?
Because there is an element of
good nature in his slave-owning
personality, he's stuck.
He can either complain that
people are treating him
unfairly--
which of course is neither here
nor there in terms of the
structure of power involved--
or he can play the fool and
pretend that he doesn't even
notice that he's being made fun
of.
Either way, this is an example
of that sly civility which
signifies on the man and which
makes it clear that while the
structure of power can't be
overthrown anytime soon,
there nevertheless is a way of
living--
at least of keeping one's sense
of humor within the existing
structure of power--
while giving the man a hard
time.
That is the set of attitudes
that Bhabha is articulating in
his notion of the hybridity of
the colonized,
which takes the form in
performance--
we're going to have a lot more
to say about performance on
Tuesday--
in performance of this sly
civility.
I think it's on page 1889 that
he gives us that expression,
which I think you should keep
hold of--
which I would compare very
closely with what Henry Louis
Gates calls
"signifyin'."
Okay.
See you on Tuesday.